I want to talk about how you got into
Eng glorious pastors can I talk about
that or no I guess so but maybe it's a
struck no no it's the Weinstein Company
which can't be struck or no it's
Universal cuz the wine scenes are in
prison so are they struck yeah I you you
can't talk about movies you did already
I don't know but I I will so let's talk
about it no but I want to know how that
happened because it's like you know um I
had known you as a director but then
when I saw first of all I one of my
favorite movies right and you were so
good in it a pleasure but did he call
you tar you know he called me
Eli sorry it's right there I liked it I
liked it that was too stupid if you set
up the dumbest one it's just going to
come out from my brain to my that was
really crafty terrible that was faster
thaned that was so [__] fast shame
yeah ring the shame Bell Quinton
Tarantino call you yes well Quenton
Tarantino and I knew each other because
he had been a big fan of my first film
cabin fever and a big vocal supporter of
it and then when we made hostile he was
a producer on it wow and he was just
like and so him putting his name as
Quenton Tarantino prevents changed the
movie it changed the perception it
changed the opening like every suddenly
it got like it's almost like you need an
artistic credit card of someone stamping
it going I like this the way Peter
Jackson gave me quotes for cabin fever
so Tarantino putting his name in house
so we came very very close and my friend
Jay is in it is that herandez that my
boys her I love J so we went um you know
we became close and and finally it was
like someone who could you know there
are very few people in Hollywood that
really give you straight advice and
honest advice and that have been through
your similar experience you know you
have that moment where you're like what
do I do next who do I trust and Quenton
was always such a good friend to me like
an older brother he's like no don't
worry about this don't buy a house yet
don't spend your money he's like he had
such great advice wow he goes after
hostle he goes don't buy a house he goes
do not buy a house until you can totally
afford to furnish it and not work for 2
years I go why he goes so many people I
know B out a house right after their
first thing and then every decision they
couldn't afford the mortgage but every
decision was based on the mortgage the
mortgage so suddenly you're an employee
of your house and you're not making the
smart career decision he's like doing
like a commercial or something Reservoir
Dogs Pulp Fiction he's like I was
sleeping on Scott spiel's couch I was
just crashing with friends I had a tiny
apartment he goes Jackie Brown was when
I bought my house cuz I didn't want to
have to be an employee of my house after
pul fiction yeah he didn't buy a house
after that it's I was like what
incredible so smart anyways so like we
had that kind of relationship um and
then with in glorious bastards he's like
you know I'd actually had him he was
writing it and he kept I was like his
Jewish fact Checker he's like Eli what
did you come he's like what did you do
this he's like what did you give
Absolution to the nais if it meant
ending the war and I was like nope we
would kill every single one of them I
was like we don't that's not a Jewish
concept I was like we're we were money
lenders we collect interest on
everything including anger we're more
pissed about [__] from 2,000 years ago
now I was like trust me the Nazis tried
to [__] wipe us off the face of the
Earth there's no reasoning with them
they must all be killed he's like okay I
got it and then I was like if you really
want to understand kind of Judaism come
to my Passover Sedar because we always
talk about the history of the Jews but
always relate it to kind of modern times
and all people who are enslaved and
bondage and how do you it's like that's
what the what the SAR is about it's
about that conscientiousness of freeing
anyone enslaved around the world and
after that Quenton was like I think I
got chapter 5 and you know I even like
he was writing it and then he's like you
know it's wrote a Boston Jews so he
heard me we were kind of doing the
Boston accents at marer which we like to
like manage
to like talking like [__] Wicked
massholes kid it's a joke um but we but
he's like I can't get the character out
of your head so I found out he was
auditioning like every other Jewish
actor but it turns out he was
auditioning them kind of against me I
sort of had it I never auditioned for it
I he had me in his head when he wrote it
and then he called me he's like and
everyone's like is Quenton going to read
I'm like I don't know so he's like hey
man I'm I'm coming to uh I'm going to
Berlin like tomorrow do you want to grab
dinner I'm like yes I go to dinner with
him he's like all right so look donz has
to be like a 360° character this can't
be like you know Death Proof or grind
house where you're just kind of coming
and be the fun I'm like wait wait wait
do I do I have the party goes yeah so
listen donowitz has to be like and he
goes and I go should we do like a toast
yeah cheers listen this can't I need the
character's history I'm like yeah I'm
[__] going method on this I'm going
to have the whole history the whole
thing in the first day of rehearsal were
you nervous no I was prepared I knew him
I been on set them we'd made movies
together I know I knew exactly what he
wanted and I knew I could deliver it so
I was [__] ready I mean there's
always that little bit of anxiety you
want to nail it but I was [__] ready
for this I was like if this is the only
thing I ever do in my lifetime this is
it this is my chance to help rein
reinvent the image of Jews Jewish men in
movies you know I love Woody Allen and
you know Jerry se you know the kind of
Adam Sandler the nebbishy funny like I
grew up on that but there weren't any
really [__] tough Jews in movies it
didn't exist so I was like this is a
chance to [__] rewrite the book and
create an icon that Jewish guys can go I
want to be that so I was up at 4 in the
morning [__] lifting weights I was I
was at the gym like 2 hours in the
morning 2 hours and 40 wow you look so
big in that movie yeah I put on well he
also you know put me next to Sam LaVine
which he's like that's true that's true
[__] hooked you up I love Sam we love
Sam you know they're doing the seven
Cubs like the size difference no but on
camera you look big but I was I would
put on 45 you know pounds of lean muscle
I was eating like every 90 minutes I
went crazy and I was like and I did the
character and then he that's how you
know Paul Russ for love and that's how I
know Paul Russ right cuz Paul Russ was
in that yeah Paul was the best we had a
great time doing that so that's where I
met Paul so I've always been following
Paul's career so I watched love from
season one I think he a brilliant show
so underrated such a good show um and
and was Brad had you known him before
that no was he nice [__] coolest wow
you're waiting for the moment for him to
snap nope never [__] nice to
everybody so psyched to be there stay
character like hangs out with the crew
one of the like as cool as I had hoped
he would be he was that cool oh my